[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí a américa el espacio de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las noticias e historias de nuestro
continente y esto es lo que veremos hoy
daniel ortega tiene el camino libre a la
reelección del presidente de nicaragua
de la mano de la fiscalía se ha
encargado de detener a la mayoría de los
candidatos opositores ya son siete los
aspirantes presidenciales arrestados y a
la lista se sumó esta semana una
candidata a la vicepresidencia
el surf debutó en tokio como deporte
olímpico y brasil se convirtió en el
primer ganador del oro de la mano de
italo ferreira el hijo de un pescador de
una de las regiones más pobres del país
una excepción en un mundo controlado por
blancos y en el que muchos atletas
denuncian racismo
y perú revive el fantasma de la
inestabilidad la oposición en el
congreso amenaza con presentar una
moción de censura en contra del primer
ministro les explicamos de qué se trata
el mecanismo que ha llevado a que el
país haya tenido cuatro presidentes en
cinco años
y vamos de inmediato a nicaragua para
revisar la imagen de la semana daniel
ortega se convirtió oficialmente en el
candidato a la presidencia del frente
sandinista de liberación nacional de
cara a las elecciones de noviembre el
mandatario aspira un cuarto mandato
consecutivo que lo mantendría en el
poder al menos hasta 2027 junto con su
esposa rosario murillo quien aspira a la
vicepresidencia el acto de confirmación
esta semana es un puro formalismo pues
ortega no tiene contrincantes ni dentro
ni fuera de su partido las autoridades
nicaragüenses leales a ortega han
emprendido una campaña de persecución a
la oposición más de 30 personas han sido
detenidas entre ellas 7 precandidatos
presidenciales y justamente esta semana
fue inhabilitada la ex reina de belleza
berenice quesada candidata a la
vicepresidencia
ortega se dirige así hacia unos comicios
prácticamente sin oposición pues el
plazo para inscribir las candidaturas ya
venció
llena de optimismo berenice que sala
acudió junto con oscar sol va barro a
escribir su fórmula presidencial ante el
consejo nacional electoral el lunes 2 de
agosto dejaron el procedimiento para
última hora justo antes de que cerrara
el plazo por la intimidación del
gobierno de daniel ortega la ola de
detenciones en la nación centroamericana
deja al menos 30 personas tras las rejas
yo trabaja necesario que el ambiente
electoral
la manera
con libertad libertaria es demasiado
que ha vivido el país nuestro país se
merece una oportunidad los nicaragüenses
se merecen una oportuna
apenas 48 horas después berenice fue
inhabilitada para ejercer cargos
públicos el partido que representan la
alianza ciudadanos por la libertad
estudia qué acciones tomar para
continuar en el proceso electoral en el
que sólo hay cuatro candidatos
registrados
desde principios de junio la fiscalidad
de ortega ha detenido a ocho
precandidatos presidenciales los acusa
de incitar a la injerencia extranjera en
sus objetivos
divulgan esa posición y se van a los
estados unidos a decir a los yankees que
hoy están listos para que lohan que los
pongan a dios en el gobierno y entonces
van a desaparecer al ejército de la
policía
y que desapareciendo a la verde la
policía van a nombrar pueblo
nicaragüense en respuesta a la unión
europea impuestos varias sanciones a
ortega y sus allegados mientras que la
organización de naciones unidas advirtió
que es poco probable que las elecciones
de noviembre sean libres y justas
y por primera vez el surf es un deporte
olímpico y brasil se convirtió en el
primer ganador de la medalla de oro en
esta competencia de la mano de vital o
ferreira ítalo es hijo de un pescador de
río grande do norte una de las regiones
más pobres de brasil comenzó a practicar
este deporte en la tapa de una nevera de
poliestireno expandido que es conocido
en perú y bolivia como techno por hoy y
ccoo por en colombia que su padre usaba
para guardar el pescado es una excepción
en un mundo controlado por los blancos
de clase media-alta muchos atletas
brasileños denuncian que hay racismo en
el solve veamos el informe en nuestro
equipo de corresponsales en el gigante
sudamericano
entre la playa de ipanema y la favela de
cantagalo no hay solamente un enjambre
de callejones un abismo social y racial
separa el mundo del sur del podio
olímpico
anderson es conocido como pikachu
comenzó a surfear a los 4 años cuando
iba a la playa con su abuela muy pronto
se dio cuenta de que tenía un don por la
tabla
comencé a destacar las personas del
mundo del surf en río de janeiro
empezaron a apoyar mi evolución en 2013
tuve la oportunidad de viajar a hawai
fue uno de los mejores viajes de mi vida
siempre le decía a mi madre que mi sueño
era viajar a hawai
a pesar de haber ganado varios torneos
locales pikachu encuentra dificultades
para conseguir patrocinios el color de
su piel cuenta mucho a la hora de atraer
a las marcas y eso a pesar de que
algunos de los mejores surfistas del
mundo son brasileños como acaba de
quedar patente en tokio con el triunfo
de italo se reirá a las virtudes no
nunca del pacto es una junta de
inscriben de la comunidad las empresas
no quieren patrocinar a los jóvenes de
la favela prefieren patrocinar a los
chicos blancos de ojos azules esto me
deja muy triste multa todo esto es
aquí aquí en río nosotros nos dedicamos
al surf sufrimos el racismo en nuestras
propias carnes pasa por muchas escuelas
y racismo erika tuvo que lidiar con ese
mismo problema desde la primera
competición supo que quería dedicarse a
este deporte pero no tuvo apoyos y optó
por el periodismo
esto de alguna forma me desmotivó
mientras que algunas amigas y colegas
viajaban a hawai a indonesia
participaban en eventos fuera de brasil
yo no tuve este soporte financiero en
aquella época por contra yo tuve una
estabilidad financiera en el periodismo
porque estaba trabajando en un canal de
televisión que cubría eventos de surf
con kanouté de chifas de coberturas de
beat surf para luchar contra la
discriminación en 2019 creó el
movimiento de surfistas negras
he creado una página en instagram una
plataforma gratuita donde empecé a
postear fotos de mujeres negras para que
estas mujeres sean vistas y para que se
conecten entre ellas surgió una red de
apoyos y de conexiones las personas se
están conociendo y están surgiendo
oportunidades de trabajo desde las redes
sociales erika intentad es construir el
estereotipo de los surfistas rubios y
erradicar lo que define como racismo
estructural
sigamos brevemente en brásil para
revisar otras noticias de las américas
esta semana
el tribunal supremo aceptó investigar al
presidente ya ir bolsonaro por sus
acusaciones infundadas de que el sistema
de votación electrónica puede ser
fraudulento el mandatario estaría
minando la credibilidad del sistema de
cara a las elecciones presidenciales de
2022 en las que sería candidato
y el presidente de eeuu joe biden
aseguró que el gobernador de nueva york
andrew cuomo debería renunciar luego de
que se conociera un informe de la
fiscalía general del estado que encontró
que acosó sexualmente a varias mujeres
como está a punto de enfrentar un
proceso de destitución en la asamblea
estatal tras perder el apoyo de varios
legisladores
y las negociaciones entre el gobierno
del presidente de venezuela nicolás
maduro y la oposición liderada por juan
guaidó estancadas desde 2019 se
reanudarán en mexico de esta forma el
país es gobernado por andrés manuel
lópez obrador se distancia más de la
posición de la organización de estados
américanos que ha condenado al gobierno
de nicolás maduro y reconoce como
presidente de venezuela a juan guaidó
la economía estadounidense sumó
novecientos cuarenta y tres mil empleos
en julio la cifra más alta desde
septiembre de 2000 20 la cifra dada a
conocer por el departamento del trabajo
es superior a la esperada por los
economistas que era de unos 870.000 el
hecho provocó alzas en la bolsa de
valores con esto el índice de desempleo
de la unión americana baja 2 céntimos
ubicándose en 5
4% el nivel más bajo en un año y medio
vamos a perú la estabilidad del país se
tambalea una vez más por cuenta del
fantasma de la moción de censura el
presidente pedro castillo eligió a guido
bellido como primer ministro una
decisión mal vista por muchos ciudadanos
y por congresistas ya que ha vendido
está siendo investigado por apología del
terrorismo varios legisladores estudian
sin invocar los mecanismos de la
constitución para declarar la vacancia
nuevamente les contamos en qué consiste
en estos mecanismos en el informe de
arianna villacorta
la incapacidad moral se incluyó en la
constitución de 1839 como un mecanismo
para retirar del poder a un mandatario
en caso de enfermedad sin embargo fue
utilizada por primera vez en 2000 para
destituir al presidente alberto fujimori
mientras él renunciaba por fax desde
japón desde entonces el congreso lo
emite sobre un asunto de interés
nacional con la finalidad de rechazar
actos realizados por un ministro
incluido el primer ministro en los
últimos años esto ha generado
inestabilidad política en perú cuatro
presidentes gobernaron en un plazo de
cinco años el congreso intentó aplicar
una moción de censura invocando la
incapacidad moral de dos de ellos pedro
pablo kuczynski y manuel merino pero
ellos terminaron renunciando a
diferencia de martín vizcarra quien fue
destituido en 2020 para que el
parlamento considere la vacancia por
incapacidad moral la oposición deberá
contar con no menos del 25 por ciento de
las firmas de los congresistas si más de
la mitad del número legal de
congresistas es decir 66 de los 130
aprueban la moción el artículo 132
y el 86 del reglamento del congreso
establecen que el ministro censurado
debe renunciar y el presidente debe
aceptar la división dentro de las
siguientes 72 horas el tema está en que
el artículo 133 de la constitución
indica que si esto sucede se produce una
crisis total del gabinete y lo común es
que renuncien todos los ministros en ese
caso el artículo 144 agrega que el
presidente de la república puede
disolver el congreso si éste ha
censurado o negado el voto de confianza
a dos consejos de ministros siempre y
cuando no esté en su último año de
gobierno algo que muchos peruanos ven
como una amenaza a la democracia
y más vidas de oakland en california
donde se inauguró un museo en honor a
las panteras negras con una recopilación
de fotografías pinturas y murales en
honor a los activistas la exhibición
resalta la historia del partido pantera
negra que fue fundado precisamente en
esa ciudad por estudiantes
universitarios
para desafiar la brutalidad policial en
eeuu contra la comunidad afro gracias
por acompañarme en esta emisión de aquí
américas hoy natalia cabrera pueden
seguirme en redes sociales en la
dirección que ven en sus pantallas en la
producción estuvo andrés doncel
recuerden que pueden ver este y otros
programas en france24 punto com
y
[Música]